ん
[音楽]
me
あなたは今
幸せですか
あなたにとっての
しあわせってい
何ですか
自分の命がう
明日
終わるかもしれない
大切な人が
明日
なくなってしまうかもしれない
そんなことを
考えている人は
どれくらい
いるでしょうか
人生は
何が起こるかなんて分かりません
だからこそ
今ある時間を
大切にしていかなければならないんです
皆さんはじめまして山田千代と申します
ねねは
30歳です職業は
航空関連会社に勤める
ごく普通のサラリーマンです
あることを除いては
そこら辺にいる
さあリーマンと何ら変わりはありません
ではなぜ
そんな僕が
皆様の前で
お話をすることがお話しする機会を頂けた
のか
それは
皆さんが
見たことのない景色を
見たことがあるかなんだぞ
思っています
では
その見たことない景色とは何なんじゃない
な何なのかっ
youtube を
やってます
山田地のちいちゃんねるって言うねあの大
身をさらしてがっつい褒め探してやってる
んですけど
おかげさまでチャンネル登録者数は10万
人を超えましてあの金の盾っていうね
左側にあるんですけどこちらの金の盾と
いうね勲章もいただけ
ああなるほど
普通のさあ今じゃなくて銀の盾をもらった
ことがある
ユーチューバーのサラリーマンっていう
ことね
と思った方もいらっしゃると思うんです
けど
実はその景色を見たっていうことだけでは
ございません
僕は
私の時に
電車にひかれるという大きな交通事故に
遭いました
正規的に
命は助かったんですけど
その際賞として
言うでだった右腕と
両足
こちらは膝よりも下がはと
下は膝にも江川
両足を
切断しました
電車にひかれて
手足
3本を
失った
新対象会社があるというのが
僕が
新しく見た景色です当時の僕は大学を辞め
て kvt 日の影響者として働き始めた
ばかりでした営業マンて面白くて
学歴とか
年齢って関係ないんですよね
何が関係している過程
数字だったんですよ数字がすべての世界で
車
学歴もなくて
まだまだ年齢も低い
この若造からすると
逆にこれはチャンスだと思いました
だってそうでしょ
みんなが
必死こいて勉強しているとか
学生生活を楽しんでいる間にこっちは
がっつり働いて
経験を積んで
そしてお金を稼ぐ
そういった可能性があるんだから
なので
とにかくがむしゃらに
働き始めました
中でも大事にしていたのは
人付き合いでしょ kk もね知識もない
僕が
一番早く
数字を取れる方法がそれだと思っていた
からです
だから営業の先輩の数字が取手人たちと
ついに行動して
いろんな経験知識を学んでいくそういった
ことをやってました事故の当日
汗から体調が悪いと感じながらも
いつものように仕事をして
いつものように
先輩達とご飯も言ってましたその回道
僕は
ホームから
倒れていっ
電車にひかれてしまいました自分の
不注意によるものです
もちろん
その記憶は
ありません
気づいたら
病院のベッドにいました車
時間も
遠く間ほどの時間が過ぎていて
最初は夢の中だと思いますよ
気球でだった右腕を
使って
目やにを取ろうとしたんですけど
見張りが取れなくてん
ないからね
てがないように見えたんですよ
ないように見えるって言うのは
指の感覚は
この辺まであったんですけど
ないからねかしーなーと思っ
宮に取れないとって母来行こうと思って
立ち上がろうと思ったら今度は派
足がないように見えるんですよ
これもての時と一緒で
足の先の感覚まではあるのに
足がないように見えだ
れそうだよなーと思って
夢にしてはちょっとリアリティやり好きだ
なあと思いながら
半信半疑のまま
顔笑に行こうと思って
ペット可立つ立ち上がろうとしたんです
けど
まあもう足はなかったので
そのまま
レッドカラー
落ちてしまって
その時の痛みが
今までの
20年間中でちまいたいんじゃないかって
くらい
入って行ってなんて
その痛みと同時に
これが
夢の世界じゃなくて
現実なんだなんていうことを痛感しました
この先ねどうしたらいいのかも分からせ
先の見えない
が暗闇におっしゃったような気分で
それこそ
毎日毎日
の体を見るために
死にたい死にたいって
これが
事故当初ん
ネガティブに捉えずドア
自分の考えです
でもそのネガティブだった自分の
考えがー
変わる出来事があるんですけど高校時代の
ね
友人が
突然女に来たんですよ
怪我をしたことを
誰にも言ってなかったんですけど
その友達たちは
僕のね
あに取れないことっていて
事故があったことは知っているものの
あさかこういったかけが尾根しているとあ
知らされてなかったみたいなんですよ
その友達たちが
自分のね
病室に入ってくれりゃいいんだよ
最初に
なんだ元気そうじゃんっていうわけですよ
自分からすると
体を隠していたから
当然
自分の体のことはいけないと思うんだけど
でも膨らみとかで
ないことぐらいは分かるから
服がだよって言う
なんか本音だったんですけど
ただ
その元気そうじゃあまりにも何か今までと
同じような反応に
とっさに僕も
たいめいじゃんみたいなあたりはいいじゃ
んってっていうか来るならちゃんと事務所
棟生みたいな感じで
日本と同じように
会話が始まって正直
くだらない事もたくさん話したんだけど
そんなこんなで時間が3時間くらい過ぎて
いて
最後に
その友達を
送る時に気づくんですよね
ケガのことを聞かれてないなって
友達が入った瞬間
エレベーターまで見送ったんだけど
友達が帰った瞬間に
そのことに気づいて
涙が止まりませんでしょ
手足がなくなってもお前はお前なんだよ
なんかそういう風に言われているような気
がして
よく考えたら両親も兄も
病院のスタッフもねー
みんな
自分の事をちゃんと見てくれてるのに
変わってしまったなって思っていたなぁ
自分だけでしょ
その晩
いろいろ考えたんだけど
よく考えたら
はいっ
手足失っただけだよなって
自分まで
変わっちゃだめじゃんって
その日からネガティブだった
自分の
マインドが
急にポジティブにいっぱいありました車
変わりましたというか変わることができ
ましたポジティブなマインドに変わると
今まで見ていた景色が全く違う景色に
見えるようになりました
両足がない
片腕がない
だから同社に登って
自分にはまだ
握手をしたり
抱き合ったり
人のぬくもりを感じられ
槍が残っている
それだけじゃなくて
大好きな人
せつな人を
見ることができる
目が合って
いい話とか
悪い話とか
お話を
人の声を聞ける意味があっていっ
そして
今もそうだけど
自分の想いを
声にして伝えることができる
口がある
あれだけで十分
幸せものじゃんって
俺にはまだまだこれだけ素敵なものがある
これだけで十分幸せものなんだって
人生は
ここで終わりシャン終わりなんかじゃなく
て
ここから
新しい
人生が始まったんです
やっぱり友達と
今までを今までのように
遊んだりもしたい
それから
そのためには自分で働かなきゃいけないし
親孝行もするためには事実をしなきゃいけ
ない
だから僕はまず最初に
膣をするという目標をつくりました22歳
になったらねみんなが大学卒業して社会人
1年生になる
じゃあそこまでに全部をお話してそこに
合わせ4社会復帰今日まずは義足の訓練を
違う病院に移って規則の訓練を1年半
かかると言われたところ
半年で終わらしてそこからすぐに
車の免許を取りに行って車の免許を取って
から今度は社会人になる前の資格とかも
取らなきゃいけないので職業訓練校に通っ
てパソコンの勉強して1年間パソコンの
勉強して
資格を何個も取って
ね
22歳の時に
皆さんと同じように
社会人して目を迎えることができましたね
一般のサラリーマンとして働いている中で
こうした youtube をやったりだ
とか
それから
去年
音の出版をしまして
本も書いたりだとか
それから義賊
僕は通常義息を吐いているんですけど
外に入れている時は義息を吐いて
自分の意思で立って歩いて行動しているん
ですけどお鶴というねアイスランドの持続
しやで言うとナンバー2の世界ナンバー2
の大きな企業の
今モデルを務めさせていただけるとか
いろいろなことをさせてもらってますケガ
をして
ネガティブだった自分がだったけどいい形
を変えて
前向きに取り組んできたら
こういう景色が
言えるようになった
みんな
それぞれの人生があります
環境も個性も同じものは決してないから
比べるなんて時間の無駄です
手足がないなら
あるものでどうするかを
考えた方が早い失った者は戻ってきません
人生はいいことばかりではありません
悪いことだって
これからもたくさんあると思いますそんな
時も
自分が今あるものは何なんだろう
できること
何なんだろう
そうやって前向きに捉えて自分としっかり
向き合ってくださいマイナスの数を数える
のではなく
+の数を拾ってあげることマイナスは状況
の中にも必ず
+なものは落ちるはずなので自分を信じて
周りの人を信じてる
そんなことにチャレンジしてみてください
そして皆さんが
こうやって生きていることって
当たり前のように
持ってる人とかもいるかもしれないけど
当たり前なんてないからね
大学で学べること
友達と何気なく遊んだりすること仕事する
ことも
恋愛だってこうやって
こうやって
何気ない
費用
過ごすということに
感謝の気持ちを
持ってください
命があるのも
当たり前なんかじゃありません
どこでどうなるかなんで
も分かりやしない
突然
なってしまうことだって
だからこそ
ありがとう
感謝の気持ちは
言葉にして
伝えるようにしてください
僕にとって
手足を失うという
大きな
マイナスは
あったけれど
そのか悪い
この完成に気付くことができたのは
僕にとって
大きな
プラスになってます今日という
何気ない
1日中
過ごせていることが一番幸せなんだって
気づいてください
最後に
もう一度
あなたはいい今
幸せですか
僕は今
とても
幸せです本日は貴重な時間をいただきまし
て本当にありがとうございました
山田治療でした